E aí
[Música]
e quando me convidaram para participar
desse evento para falar com jovens
estudantes de tecnologia o que pensando
como que eu poderia de fato contribuir
para a vida deles para os estudos para o
trabalho e uma das coisas mais
importantes que passou na minha cabeça é
que eles saibam reconhecer um ambiente
com cultura de inovação
eu me lembrei quase de imediato de 2003
as atos 17 anos atrás naquela época
estudava engenharia pela manhã e à tarde
eu e um amigo acabamos por criar um
pequeno negócio uma empresa que
construirá sites uma época em que apenas
cinco porcento da população era
conectada
e eu jovem como vocês queria meu
unicórnio aí a buscar minha empresa uma
empresa grande e por incrível que pareça
naquela época a maior dificuldade Nossa
nosso maior desafio era convencer o
empresário e criar um site era
importante e mais do que isso essa minha
busca por esse unicórnio acabou por me
levar conhecer uma fazenda de unicórnio
e outros bichos também um belo dia eu
fui convidado a conhecer um vice
presidente de uma grande construtora
eles estavam procurando um estagiário e
obviamente aquilo não brilhou tanto meus
olhos seu estagiário já tinha uma
Startup mas estou param negociar eu
coloquei quanto que eu queria ganhar
se eu pedir um cargo e por incrível que
pareça eles toparam viram Potencial em
mim e quando eu disse que tinha uma
pequena empresa se não incomodou ele
deixaram que eu seguisse com aquela
pequena empresa a minha Startup e aquilo
mexeu comigo
é mas eu ainda estava incomodado
não tem horário para chegar o horário
para sair chefe tem que dar satisfação
eu era um menino tinha uma Startup da
engenharia e aquilo certa forma me
deixou bastante incomodado
e de repente o cabelo Vivendo em
situações de participar de coisas muito
legais eu tava dormindo ia sentado em
mesas de reunião com presidente da
empresa e de repente eles começaram a me
ouvir e não era só comigo eu percebi que
jovens eram ouvidos as ideias eram
ouvidas que a gente se via o dando a
direção da empresa desenvolvendo Novos
Produtos desenvolvendo novos processos e
que fica a primeira dica
e procure um ambiente que oferece
liberdade de verdade para você dar sua
opinião e verdade para você expor suas
ideias e para participar do negócio mas
oferecer Liberdade não é tarefa fácil
muitos líderes têm dificuldade de
colocar os jovens os processos criativos
deixar que as pessoas participem do
processo de criação de inovação Mas aí
tem um problema
é porque as ideias precisam se encontrar
precisa ver colaboração
e em um evento realizado aqui no Ted há
um tempo atrás mestre Delei jornalista
bastante conhecido e o pesquisador sobre
inovação trouxe um conceito muito
interessante que as ideias fazem sexo
e Como assim 10 fazem sexo é as ideias
precisam se encontrar
um conceito diferente e ele fez isso de
propósito para chamar atenção da
importância da troca a importância da
colaboração muitas vezes uma ideia nasce
e é transformada por outra pessoa que em
seguida é transformada por mais outra
pessoa e daí na assim ideias ainda
melhores ainda mais adaptadas para
aquela realidade então que fica minha
segunda dica procurem ambientes Onde
existe colaboração as pessoas precisam
colaborar com ideias precisam participar
e ao conjunto de ideias que fazem as
melhores ideias
e eu na minha história eu tava
exatamente em um ambiente de colaboração
junto com o time multidisciplinar a
gente tava em um projeto Adivinhe que
exatamente colocando a construtora para
vender imóveis pela internet aquele
momento onde apenas cinco porcento da
população era conectada o modelo
predominante era vender imóveis por
jornais impressos Exatamente isso as
construtoras ligavam para os jornais
para anunciar os seus imóveis em
pequenos anúncios que eles chamavam de
tijolinho e os clientes tinham que ir lá
na banca comprar o jornal e localizar os
imóveis de interesse e com esse projeto
de internet aquela época Por incrível
que pareça começou a dar certo aquele
grupo de trabalho começou a ter
resultado e as vendas pela internet
começaram a crescer exponencialmente
a e nesse momento eu acabei sendo
convidados e sócio da empresa e aquilo
não foi só comigo para os jovens da
época e ainda hoje são convidados nessa
empresa a serem sócios do negócio
o que aquilo me fez ficar aos poucos a
gente foi passando os clientes da minha
Startup para outras Pequenas Empresas a
gente foi desativando aquela Startup e
eu resolvi me dedicar aquele novo
negócio aquele empreendimento que eu
participava e além de liberdade e
colaboração é muito importante que a
Inovação tem a direção e qual direção
tomar procure a direção que te leve a
uma melhor experiência do cliente vamos
lembrar naquela época onde a compra de
imóveis era feita por jornais impressos
Como era a experiência do cliente se
tinha que esperar Às quartas e aos
domingos quando os jornais com caderno
de imóveis era veiculado você tinha que
esperar o banco abrir e a banca comprar
um jornal levar o jornal para cá
eu abrir encontrar Aquele monte de
tijolinho com pouca informação sem foto
e ficar caçando ofertas e tentar a sorte
né Então aquela experiência muito ruim
muito negativa nos incomodavam a dor do
cliente nos incomodava então a gente
resolveu investir nessa direção melhorar
a experiência do cliente mesmo com 15
por cento da população conectada a gente
sabia que aquela era a nossa direção por
outro lado existem inúmeros outros
exemplos na indústria de empresas que
não apontaram essa direção a experiência
do cliente e 95 a Kodak era a maior
produtora de filmes de fotografia do
planeta
e é mas a experiência de bater uma foto
com filme não era tão legal vamos
lembrar que para ter uma foto você
precisava comprar um filme e tinha um
número limitado de fotos o filme tinha
lá 12 fotos 24 fotos e algumas dessas
fotos ficaram muito Ficava muito mal
tiradas você tinha que acabar revelando
essas fotos que acabava tendo que ir
empresas para que revelasse a pote que
sair da sua casa e pagar por aquela
revelar aquela Revelação e aquilo Me
incomodava as pessoas eu não era uma
experiência legal é que faltava dinheiro
para Kodak vestindo tecnologia
há 12 anos depois HP minha empresa
californiana lá do Vale do Silício
apresentava para o mercado uma câmera
digital e além da câmera uma impressora
por apenas 400 dólares em casa você
conseguia bater suas fotos escolher
Quais fotos você iria imprimir e tava
resolvido então naquele momento que
faltou para Kodak outro direção direção
que lado a experiência do cliente vamos
lembrar outro Keys interessante a
Blockbuster já foi a maior locadora de
filmes do planeta
e no crava através de taxas de atraso
pelas entregas dos filmes depois dos
DVD's vamos imaginar como era a
experiência na época você depois do
final de semana tinha que se dirigir a
Blockbuster para entregar um filme
muitas vezes em filme que não tava
rebobinado isso a fita que você tinha
que rebobinar e de repente por não ter
rebobinado seu filme você tinha que
pagar uma multa
e se tivesse atrasado por exemplo
algumas horas você também tinha que
pagar multa
E por incrível que pareça naquela época
a Netflix chegou a sondar a Blockbuster
para uma parceria para oferecer uma
experiência diferente uma experiência
onde o cliente poderia ver o filme de
casa e a Blockbuster não aceitou
e ela não tinha essa visão de futuro ela
não tinha essa direção para experiência
do cliente e o que aconteceu hoje a
Netflix em quase 200 milhões de
assinantes pagantes e a Blockbuster como
todo mundo sabe deixou de existir
Oi e o quê que mais faltou para
Blockbuster e para Kodak coragem de
assumir risco e mudar a direção do
negócio mudar é assumir risco que fica
uma terceira dica importante coragem de
assumir risco a gente sabe que todo novo
empreendimento tá cisco mas o maior
risco é você não correr nenhum risco
Oi gente sabe que tecnologia e
comportamento humano são coisas que vão
mudar não tem como a gente impedir
bom então não vamos ficar esperando esse
futuro acontecer Vamos Construir esse
futuro e às vezes é muito importante
mexer em time que está ganhando
o bicho trazer aqui um exemplo de mexer
em time que está ganhando vamo pegar o
exemplo da Amazon a maior varejista de
livros físicos do mundo quando ela viu o
surgimento de um livro digital né de um
dispositivo eletrônico aquilo incomodou
ela então ela teve coragem de mudar sua
direção por quê Porque experiência de
comprar um livro não era uma experiência
legal pelo preço que ela disponibilidade
muitas vezes pela falta do livro então
ela teve coragem de investir em um
projeto de livros digitais e criou o
Kindle que hoje é o maior dispositivo de
leitura digital do mundo mesmo assumindo
o risco de eliminar uma parte relevante
do seu negócio então ao invés dela
esperar de uma empresa
a classe esse mercado dela foi ela que
teve a coragem EA iniciativa de criar o
seu próprio dispositivo
e muitas vezes a gente acha que esses
exemplos estão distantes vou trazer para
vocês uma situação que eu estou passando
agora passa a construtora é uma
consultora da América Latina vivíamos
exclusivamente de vender imóveis temos
uma marca reconhecida geramos lucro
poderíamos estar acomodados mas se de
repente a empresa talvez linda de Fora
resolver se oferecer uma experiência
melhor de moradia que a gente Talvez um
aluguel com preço acessível cheia de
serviços com conveniências para o
cliente e desculpe tá nosso negócio
então em vez de esperar se ele escutado
e a gente resolveu fazer a nossa própria
descrição resolvemos criar uma Startup
de aluguel também cheia de serviço cheio
de conveniências Porque queremos buscar
uma experiência diferenciada por nosso
cliente nesse projeto eu vi os quatro
aspectos que você tem que buscar no
ambiente de inovação Liberdade
colaboração
o foco na experiência do cliente e
coragem para assumir riscos tivemos a
coragem de desafiar nosso próprio
negócio saia do aluguel é uma das frases
comerciais mais utilizadas por nós mas
mesmo assim passamos a oferecer o
aluguel com uma ótima opção e os dois
negócios conseguem conviver juntos
e harmonicamente um negócio obviamente
Desafio o outro e esse desafio surge
para a performance ainda melhor agora
deixa eu falar para vocês algo
importante
é para levar precisa ambientes de
inovação mais importante do que a
inspiração é a transpiração e junto da
transpiração venha resiliência
Oi gente sabe que momentos difíceis vão
surgir
e não ter altos e baixos mesmo nos
grandes negócios Então seja resiliente
nesses momentos imagine agora na
pandemia quanto os negócios estão
passando por tremendas dificuldades
e Talvez existam outros animais que
representem melhor que uma empresa
precisa ser além de unicórnio
Oi Alex Lázaro trouxe um conceito das
startups camelo o que eu achei muito
interessante porque os cabelos precisam
de poucos recursos são animais
resistentes e conseguem caminhar longas
distâncias
bom então é isso Pessoal espero que como
eu vocês possam encontrar ambientes Onde
existe inovação para Que ela possa
alimentar unicórnios camelos e outros
bichos mais obrigado